Warzone 2.0 launches today and
Activision is marking the end of the
original war zone with a Twitter post
asking fans to press F to pay respects
this of course is a call back to the
popular meme that references a scene
from 2014's Advanced Warfare Warzone
Caldera as it will be called will be
offline for 12 days returning on
November 28th if all goes to plan
Activision will continue to support the
game but the extent to which it will do
so is unknown but the launch of the new
war zone isn't the only thing happening
today the first season for Call Of Duty
Modern Warfare 2 and Warzone 2.0 is also
out now ushering in a new battle pass
more maps additional weapons and Bug
fixes the full patch notes for the
season 1 update have been posted online
so let's walk through a couple of the
major bullet points the season one patch
includes a range of weapons balancing
changes including the M4 scene hip
spread reduction the cast of 545 having
its ads speed increase and a general
Nerf to a variety of guns like the
Lockwood 300 which sees its damage range
reduced in terms of new content Modern
Warfare 2's multiplayer has brought back
shoot house but it looks a little
different as well as a new operator Zeus
who can be unlocked instantly by
purchasing the battle pass the new
hardcore mode which is called Tier 1 is
also live in Modern Warfare 2. but
unfortunately for some Treyarch
announced that Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 CDL Mosh Pit playlist will be
slightly delayed the feature was
originally scheduled for release at the
start of season 1 but due to bugs it
will now come at a later date Treyarch
said fixing the CDL mosh pit bugs is
quote top priority and it will have an
update on the potential release date as
soon as possible Modern Warfare 2 CDL
Mosh Pit will include three official
game modes hardpoint Search and Destroy
and control with the League's standard
rules and restrictions applied the CDL
Mosh Pit playlist is meant to be a
pre-cut cursor to ranked play which is
set to release in 2023 so far we know
that there will be a ranked top 250
leaderboard ranked skill divisions and
of course rewards Call of Duty Black Ops
Cold War league play and Call of Duty
Vanguard ranked play will be phased out
during November players will have until
November 22nd to secure remaining
rewards but also new in Warzone 2.0 is
DMZ in which players can work together
to complete objectives there are locked
areas on the map that players can open
with specific Keys once they find them
players will fight against other human
and AI characters with the aim of
getting to the chopper for xville I'll
leave a link to the full list of patch
notes in the description below and while
you're there leave a comment letting me
know which item on the battle pass is
your favorite so far
foreign